vous n'êtes pas trop et poursuivi en
justice elle passe en ce moment c'est
ses journées au tribunal alors le
problème c'est pour quelle raison alors
c'est pour un accident de ski et qui a
eu lieu il y a 7 ans qu'un homme
l'accuse d'avoir provoqué et lui demande
d'ailleurs 3 millions d'euros de
réparation pour le traumatisme subi le
procès est filmé et surtout il est
lunaire aucun trucage dans cette vidéo
capturée par une caméra embarquée sur
cette autoroute à Los Angeles un
accident va se produire imprévisible et
impressionnant
[Musique]
malchanceux le compte conducteur de la
citadine s'en sort bien semblait sur
grave
[Musique]
incroyable
restaurant
la manif pour tous le collectif a fêté
ses 10 ans hier et décidé de changer de
nom et c'est le syndicat de la famille
qu'il a emporté parmi les différentes
propositions on avait également
collectif pas métissés ou le ministère
amen le pape François se lance dans le
rap qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
histoire même la preuve en tous les cas
en images regardez cette photo
grosse bagouse
lunettes fumée doudoune façon Puff Daddy
on est plus sur DJ Vatican qui
retournerait la place Saint-Pierre que
sur sa santé le pape François sauf que
cette photo du pape François vêtue d'une
longue doudoune blanche est fausse elle
a été générée par une intelligence
artificielle alors il y a certes un
petit côté ludique mais aussi un aspect
nettement plus inquiétant que je vais
vous raconter ce matin oui parce que
c'est vraiment hyper bien fait quoi
comment comment ça marche comment c'est
possible tout le monde peut essayer à la
maison si on veut s'amuser bien sûr
puisque c'est gratuit il faut se créer
un compte sur la messagerie discord qui
est une entreprise basée à San Francisco
et c'est à partir de cette messagerie
discorde qu'on peut s'adresser à une
intelligence artificielle qui crée des
images un nouveau nom donc mais le
mouvement lui continue de prôner un
modèle de famille libre traditionnel
c'est-à-dire qu'un enfant doit avoir une
maman un papa et une jeune fille au père
qui fait des bijoux à papa avec la
langue quand maintenant on fait des
courses
[Applaudissements]
je refuse pourquoi tu me l'as pas dit
parce que j'ai pas mis la télé
à cause de leurs mots
[Applaudissements]
qui est ma mère
et qui est à la chance de profiter de sa
retraite depuis peu on aime on aime bien
son gendre ça va
c'est un mensonge on se quitte avec la
traditionnelle l'image du jour et
aujourd'hui c'est Dieu qui fait un petit
coucou au nouveau syndicat de la famille
sympa de sa part
à la maison il est sympa
ta maison vraiment ça me ferait plaisir
quoi
tout ce qui est à base de fromage j'aime
bien sachant que je suis intolérant au
lactose donc ouais mais c'est pas grave
je fais je fais quand même avec en fait
c'est mon péché mignon mais ça veut dire
que vous digérez hyper mal je le digère
pas bien oui c'est à dire que voilà je
j'ai des selles un peu particulières
je m'attendais pas à ça aujourd'hui
l'art s'invite partout même sur les
cuvettes de toilette Lourdes en plus
donc de qualité c'est toi design qui
fait ça toi alors toi design
voilà c'est bien parce que vous avez
donné descriptions de vous absolument
parfaites pour que le fromage vous
cherchez donc une femme entre 20 et 40
ans c'est ça oui j'ai pas très difficile
entre 20 et 40 ans il faut qu'elle aime
le fromage pas trop la neige je suis pas
très fan de chocolat donc pas trop de
chocolat non plus mais je suis pas du
tout
ce qui vient voilà et alors si en plus
si en plus vous êtes gastro-entérologue
vraiment soyez la bienvenue alors c'est
parfait les lignes automatiques du métro
sont visiblement propice aux rencontres
en tout cas à Paris c'est ce qui ressort
d'une étude menée par le site de
rencontre happen selon elle c'est la
ligne une si tu entre la défense et
château de Vincennes à Paris qui arrive
en tête avec 31% de célibataires qui y
croise le plus de personnes qui leur
plaisent voilà on ne retrouve ensuite
les lignes 14 et 4 toutes les deux à 18%
la ligne 9 la ligne 13 Nico viens me
rejoindre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au contraire alors là si vous empruntez
la 8 c'est la 10 la 11 la 3 bis et la 7
bis maintenant beaucoup moins de chance
de matchs avec le grand amour sur ces
lignes entre trois seulement et 13% de
célibataire croise des personnes qui
leur plaisent et donc combler un vide tu
penses à moi je te remercie beaucoup tu
es le plus beau des plateaux c'est bien
c'est bien c'est en tout cas ton manche
est énorme bah justement c'est un
hommage
oh c'était classe oh c'était bien allez
pouet pouet on referme cette ces
actualités avec un anniversaire
merci
[Musique]
et 25 ans alors qu'est-ce qu'on dit
merci